this is a run on a bank this is also a
run on a bank and while these people
lost their money these people didn't
thanks to a government agency designed
back then we do not want and will not
have another epidemic of bank failures
the FDIC exists to ensure your money is
safe and that bank closures don't rattle
the U.S economy here's how it works and
what happens when your bank fails let's
start back with these people in the
middle of the Great Depression they were
afraid their Banks would go out of
business and their money would vanish so
they'd run to withdraw it all first but
the issue as President Franklin
Roosevelt explained at the time was when
you deposit money in a bank the bank
does not put the money into a safe
deposit vault
it invests your money in many different
forms of credit he means your bank
doesn't have enough cash on hand to pay
out all their Accounts at once not back
then or today so during a run the bank
would have to suspend business and most
would then completely fail thousands of
them did which just made other people
panic about their money so they'd run to
their bank and that's how a bank run on
One bank can become contagious to other
Banks so FDR signed the Banking Act of
1933 creating the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation the FDIC to make
people have faith their money was safe
in a U.S Bank it worked your government
does not intend that the history of the
past few years shall be repeated
the FDIC is what it sounds like
insurance for every hundred dollars you
deposit your bank has to put a few cents
into the fdic's deposit Insurance Fund
this is what's used to reimburse you the
depositor should your bank fail but only
up to a certain amount currently if you
have 250 000 or less in a bank all that
money is insured any amount in a bank
account over that is uninsured you could
in theory lose it if the bank fails this
applies not only to personal accounts
but also to businesses
when a bank is on the brink of failure
the FDIC along with a regulatory agency
gets involved typically they arrange to
sell the bank to another usually larger
bank then close the failed bank trying
to make the process seamless for the
bank's customers taking the failed Bank
selling it to a healthy bank will ensure
that there's continuity continuity of
services to the community that the bank
serves not just protecting insured
deposits which the FDIC always does but
usually the buyers would would pay
enough to cover the uninsured too they
wanted the uninsured because those were
large deposits and then also continued
servicing the loans keep the credit
lines open you know all the services
that bank provides
over the years most failed banks have
been small here they are skilled by size
except for this one Washington Mutual in
2008 the largest bank failure in U.S
history most of the accounts primarily
personal accounts were insured and the
bank was sold for enough money to cover
the insured no need to even touch the
deposit fund but also cover the
uninsured accounts but the bank failures
of 2023 haven't been routine
with Silicon Valley Bank the vast
majority of depositors had accounts with
more than two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars so they're uninsured it's a lot
of businesses
and because the bank began to fail so
quickly the FDIC hadn't lined up a buyer
before they had to close it their
deposit base was a very like close-knit
group of VCS and their portfolio
companies and were just spread like fire
when you know what a couple of them got
worried they all started to run so the
U.S announced all customers who had
deposits in these Banks can rest assured
rest assured they'll be protected
experts say guarantee not just the
insured but also the uninsured was aimed
at stopping any further economic damage
from these businesses not making payroll
but also might have stopped other
uninsured account holders from running
if the uninsured depositors in Bank a
can't access their funds that's going to
make the depositors in Bank B nervous we
have contagion and then we're back to
1933. reimbursing all these depositors
will come from the eventual sale of the
bank and also from the Insurance Fund
many experts are worried the amount
banks have to contribute may go up so
your bank fees could too a process that
while Messi worked the way it was
designed nearly a hundred years ago I
can assure you my friend that it is
safer to keep your money in a reopened
Bank than it is to keep it under the
mattress
I think on the one hand FDR would be
wincing and saying oh man I thought we
wouldn't have screw-ups like this on the
other hand I think he would smile and
say ah it didn't spread we haven't had
contagion we haven't had widespread runs
that was my goal in creating the FDIC